Now, you may actually remember the first postulate from Unit 4.
Let's say you wake up in a train but this isn't just any train--this is the train of physics.
And the thing that's so nice about the train of physics is that it has a completely smoother ride,
it's silent, and the track is completely straight,
also the windows are blacked out, so you can't see outside.
Let's say you just woke up in this train and you don't know if it's still,
if it's at rest or if it's moving in a constant speed.
My question is what experiment can you do to determine if the train is moving at a constant speed
of it's at rest in the tracks.
Maybe you could drop objects and absorb their trajectory if they fall.
Maybe you could push objects along the floor of the train and maybe by pushing them forwards
or pushing them backwards, you can see something different if the train is moving.
Or maybe you can hang a pendulum from the ceiling and if the train is moving forward,
may be the pendulum would behave in some strange way.
Okay, so I want you to think about these options and select all that apply before you hit submit.